okay everybody raise your hand if you
have ever been personally victimized by
Regina George well even if you haven't
you're about to get another chance with
the latest version of The Mean Girl
Story almost 20 years after the original
movie had us wearing pink on Wednesdays
and contemplating the merits of creating
a burn book The Gang is back and it's
not just a remake it's a movie version
of the Broadway musical which was based
on the original movie and I thought I'd
get a jump on things and tell you
everything we know so far about this
upcoming flick okay despite the fact
that there was a recent Target
commercial featuring almost all of the
main cast from the OG movie don't expect
the new movie to revolve around the
likes of Lindsay Lohan Rachel McAdams
Amanda safreed and Lacy chabar or to
even have them period because the new
movie like the original is focused on a
group of high schoolers and not to be
rude but I don't think any of those
lovely actresses from the first one can
convincingly play like class of 2025 so
the main cast is a bunch of younger
upand cominging Stars more on them in a
minute as far as the original cast the
only ones who have been verified as
being in the new movie are Tina Fay and
Tim Meadows they play Miss norbury and
principal Duvall respectively now as far
as the original cast of girls that's a
little more unknown on the movies IMDb
page they aren't anywhere to be found
but Studios have been known to hide fun
cameos by not including actors on that
site plus a couple of the cast members
are on record as saying they would be
utterly down to be a part of the new one
for example Rachel McAdams AKA Regina
said a while back that she was fully
into it I would never say no to Tina
feay ever ever ever she's also on record
saying that Tina is the greatest adding
so we'll see how it all shakes out was
that a koi way of saying that she's in
the movie we'll find out but even Rachel
isn't in the movie she clearly has
nothing but love for Renee rap who is
playing the iconic Regina character I
don't think she can do any wrong she's
already got me beat with that voice
so I'm just excited to see her
Incarnation and then there's Amanda
safreed who played the hilarious Karen
in the first one in a red carpet
interview she echoed Rachel mcadam's
love for the movie and when asked if
she'd be willing to be in the new movie
she said four of us are 100% into it
yeah of course like the McAdams
interview this was from before filming
started for the upcoming movie so who
knows what happened since then so that
brings us to the actors we do know are
in the movie there's the lovely Inori
Rice playing the lead role of K
you probably know her from things like
May of East Town or Spider-Man no way
home so that role is in excellent hands
cuz she's super talented singer actress
and allaround badass Renee rap is
playing Regina George which isn't a huge
shock considering she also played the
part on Broadway but in case you were
wondering if that meant it was boring to
play the part once again for the movie
nope it's honestly more fun than I even
thought it would be it's so much fun it
feels like Theater Camp it's like
amazing Renee isn't the only one who was
also in the musical Ashley Park played
the role of Gretchen on Broadway and was
asked to join the movie as well though
interestingly she's not playing Gretchen
that role went to BB wood who is known
primarily for her part in love Victor
Ashley is instead playing a character
named Madame Park who is the school's
French teacher alii Calio plays Janice
and she was more than happy to mess with
her look to play the part they cut all
my hair off and they dyed it green I'm
having a great time I'm singing the
songs she also talked about how much fun
it was to film and how the directors of
the movie Samantha Jane and archero
Perez Jr were having just as much fun as
the cast on set and she pointed out that
their background really aligned well
with the movie perfect for the job I
love that they come from also a music
background because they're making
choices that are so very different from
what we would usually see in film long
one takes taking time to really
appreciate the live vocal elements of
songs there are some other great young
actors like jaquel Spivey avantica vapu
and Christopher Briney rounding out the
cast of high schoolers plus we get some
fun cameos in the form of Jenna Fisher
AKA Pam from The Office and byy Phillips
playing Katie and Regina's moms
respectively and these days it doesn't
seem like you can make any comedy
without John H in the cast and Mean
Girls is no exception he plays coach
Carr the incompetent sexed teacher in an
interview Tina feay talked about her
approach to making an updated version of
a movie She Wrote 20 years ago I tried
to update it but I also always try I
don't try to chase like slang or
anything that people are saying now
because by the time it takes a long time
to make a movie and it'll be over by the
time the movie comes out she also talked
about how they decided to write a bunch
of new music for the movie so it
wouldn't just be a straightup remake of
The Mean Girls musical in a cast
interview she talked about her husband
Jeff Richmond who wrote all the music
for both Productions after the cast
gushed about Jeff for a
[Applause]
bit Tina talked about how great it was
for Jeff to get to make new music for
this project yeah and it's been
thrilling to see him get to like
continue to transform all this music so
the movie comes out in theaters on
January 12th 2024 until then you can
watch and rewatch the trailer to get a
tiny fix of this hilarious movie it was
actually slated to get released on
Paramount plus but then the studio
decided it would be better to have it in
theaters first so get your tickets soon
now if you're anything like me you're
just getting psyched to check out the
latest in the Mean Girls Universe the
mgu the thought of seeing a movie based
off a musical based off a movie is well
fetch there I said it you happy of
course you are cuz a new Mean Girls
movie is headed your way have any
thoughts about it put them in our burn
book aka the comment
section